this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash bio to get a
two-year plan with a huge discount plus
a bonus month and a free gift more on
them in just a bit
today's protagonist was called the
highest and the culminating point that
beauty has attained in the sphere of
music or even the musical christ these
options do not come from just any
classical music enthusiast but some guy
called tchaikovsky who knew a thing or
two about composition he was preferring
to wolfgang amadeus mozart possibly the
greatest musical genius to ever grace
our ears and souls here at biographics
we admit that we don't necessarily have
the knowledge to analyze in-depth
mozart's compositions we will do our
best however to cover his short yet
incredibly eventful life and we'll also
debunk a couple of myths along the way
wolfgang amadeus mozart was born in
salzburg on january 27 1756. he was the
seventh child of anna maria and leopold
composer for the local prince archbishop
count schrattenbach since burst his
parents and siblings called him woolfer
the princess bishopric of salzburg was
one of many small sovereign states
within the holy roman empire and an
extremely wealthy one the environment
may have been provincial compared to
other large european capitals but arts
and music enjoyed the patronage of the
court leopold soon realized that wolfel
was endowed with an extraordinary
musical talent at the age of three he
could play his first pieces on the piano
at four the violin woolfell's sister
nanil displayed similar abilities soon
leopold was dedicating most of his
energies to developing their natural
skills the boy appeared to be the most
gifted of the two absorbing musical
theory with much appetite and little
effort under leopold's loving but
inflexible guidance woolfell composed
his first piano concerto age four
followed by a minuet and a trio for
keyboard at six in between these two
accomplishments the young mozart
discovered the joys of singing and
performing live in 1761 the
five-year-old had a minor role in the
musical drama sigismund king of hungary
this first experience of the theatrical
stage may have influenced his love of
opera in later life around this time
leopold realized that salzburg was too
small for wolferl and nanelle the dad
became an impresario and planned a trip
to the imperial court in vienna in
october of 1762. emperor francis the
first and empress maria theresa welcomed
the tiny performers at their lavish
shamroom palace maria theresa was
astonished at wolfgang's skills spoiling
him with compliments and presence to
express his gratitude the boy jumped on
the empress's lap and kissed her but the
emperor wanted to challenge the boy even
further he asked him to play the piano
keys covered by a screen and then to
play using only one finger wolfgang
accepted and won the challenge now a
celebrity the boy became a sort of
mascot for the ladies it caught one day
he slipped to the floor while at courts
and an archdust just lifted woolfell to
his feet and he told her you are a dear
good lady and you shall be my wife the
good lady was marie antoinette the
future queen of france
leopold had hit upon a winning idea
courts around europe would pay good
money to see his children perform the
mozart's continued their triumville
albeit exhausting tour of europe
leopold's tactics may appear akin to
exploitation of child labor but it
appears that his children and especially
wolfgang greatly enjoyed their travels
and their performances for the future
composer they were also an occasion to
hone his skills and explore new musical
genres in april 1764 leopold warfare and
nana toured london where the boy prodigy
was challenged by lawyer danes
barrington to improvise two arias in the
popular style of italian opera after a
short moment of reflection wolfgang
hammered at the harpsichord delivering
both a love song and a song of rage the
anecdote proves how the young talent
could effectively internalize and
reproduce the standard conventions of
popular genres at the time the tour
resumed with stops in flanders france
switzerland and salzburg before the
mozart's return to vienna in 1768. the
new emperor joseph ii commissioned the
12-year-old mozart to compose an opera
la finta semleche which attracted the
brave italian master pietro matatacio
not bad for a pre-teen but the hype
around the opera attracted the envy of
the imperial entourage due to their
scheming the opera did not reach the
stage but leopold and wolfgang and set
their minds on conquering the operatic
world to do so they had to take by storm
the cradle of lyrical theatre italy
in december of 1769 they crossed the
alps for a tour of northern italy where
wolfgang continued to impress audiences
with his operatic improvisations
according to a newspaper published in
vienna four verses were submitted to him
on which he composed on the spot on aria
in the best taste in the very act of
singing it eventually wolfgang received
another commission for an opera at the
age of 14 he saw his mithridates king of
ponto opening in milan to rave reviews
the success was quickly followed by
another milanese debut aschiano and alba
the italian tour continued from strength
to strength while in bologna he attended
the lessons of gian batista martini
mastering counterpoint or the art of
combining different melodic lines and
musical composition martini was
impressed and he encouraged mozart to
take the entrance exam for the
philharmonic society he was given a
musical theme and was instructed to
build a fugue for four instruments
around it a fugue is a composition where
a theme is introduced at the beginning
and then repeated at different pitches
half an hour later wolfgang had
completed the composition performed it
and bagged his diploma next stage of the
tour rome and the vatican where wolfgang
performed another stunt he attended a
performance of choral work misery by
alegri no printed copies of the
composition existed and the pope himself
had forbidden it from being transcribed
but he memorized the entire score and
put it a paper in secret after the
performance the next day he played and
sang it flawlessly to an audience of
gasping musicians he was now the talk of
rome although some envious souls gossip
that his talents lay in a magical ring a
sort of talisman that he wore all the
time however our genius simply removed
the ring and proved that he could still
rock those ivory keys no magic involved
what a surprise the triumph was now
complete young mozart was granted an
audience with pope clement xiv who
appointed him knight of the order of the
golden spur
[Music]
in the spring of 1772 mozart returned to
salzburg looking for permanent
employment he founded at the court of
the new prince archbishop count colorado
who hired him as a concert master with a
rather low salary of 150 gilders the
composer was not over the moon yet these
were productive years the musician
penned further operas and his first
piano concerto he also perfected his
technique as he studied the works of
joseph hayden and the imperial court
composer antonio celieri now let's take
a quick break here antonio celieri is
remembered by most as the patron saint
of mediocrity a fashionable composer
whose work did not stand the test of
time consumed by jealousy who was
embroiled in a bit of rivalry against
mozart a feud which resulted in salieri
accelerating mozart's death at least
that's the plot of the film amadeus by
milosh forman which is based on the play
by peter schaefer inspired by a previous
work of alexander pushkin and it was all
based on unfounded gossip i'll get to
this later but rest assured that the two
composers largely respected each other
and that our friend antonio never killed
anybody in 1777 the only one who had a
beef with mozart was his employer count
colorado unappreciative of his
compositions and operating on a tight
budget the prince of salzburg laid off
his constant master now age 21 mozart
set off on a new voyage in search of
patronage this time his father had to
stay and work in salzburg so mum anna
maria was to accompany the musical
marvel so how would wolfgang fare
without leopold's invasive yet steadying
influence
in 1777 and 1778 wolfgang and mum saw
work in augsburg munich and mannheim but
work remained elusive there are many
reasons for this first wolfgang had
grown into a playful yet overconfident
young man a confidence which
bordered on arrogance he lacked the
diplomacy to function in an aristocratic
court and spoke his mind to wealthy
patrons this resulted in being snubbed
in favor of more accommodating rivals
the second reason is the mozart was
going through a massive composer's block
in 1777 and 1778 he wrote to his father
that he was working on numerous projects
and that he and anna maria were living
like royalty to the point that he had
grown slightly fat but not as fat as the
fib he was telling his dad the musician
was going through exceptional
difficulties in writing new pieces for
example in late 1777 mozart had been
commissioned for three flute concertos
by a dutch patron he soon got stuck
urged by his father to honour the
contract mozart simply retrieved a
previous work and oboe concerto and
changed the solo part to that of a flute
but he delivered only two out of the
three concertos and he had to forfeit
the payment of 200 guilders mozart's
flute gate debunks the myth that the
composer could crank out new music
easily and could devise new works in his
head before transcribing them without
revision or afterthought the myth
originates from a letter attributed to
mozart published by magazine editor
johann roschlitz decades after his death
the whole piece though it be long stands
almost finished and completed my mind so
that i can survey it like a fine picture
or a beautiful statue at a glance so
mozart's music came from a higher plane
and reached his mind fully formed
through a stroke of divine inspiration
except no it didn't the letter was a
forgery the secret to mozart's genius
was constant practice study revision
more study and more practice even if he
conceived as main themes in his head
mozart still had to sit at the keyboard
to refine them work out their variations
and orchestrations a long
mind-shattering process which day after
day was bound to cause mental fatigue by
his own admission mozart struggled the
most with string quartets when writing
an orchestral piece for example he would
first create the main theme for the main
treble instrument next he nailed the
bass lines and finally the inner parts
and orchestrations but when tackling a
quartet he wrote the four parts at the
same time baa baa baar placing a great
deal of effort in building a complex
counterpoint this is what made him sweat
the most wolfgang amadeus mozart was an
exceptionally talented and hardworking
human but he was a human after all and
as any other 21 year old he was prone to
another source of distraction after
germany anna maria and wolfgang were due
to visit versailles the trip was
thwarted when mozart met the first great
love of his life the young and beautiful
singer aloisia weber he followed her in
a tour to the hague and even supported
her family financially to leopold's
concern dad sent anamaria to retrieve
him and finally the two set off for
paris but their french experience was a
terrible one they were expecting to be
welcomed at court but all mozart could
find were some teaching jobs and he
could only afford a rather sleazy hotel
as they spiraled into poverty anna maria
fell ill and eventually died on the
third of july 1778.
all right we'll get back to our video in
just a second but first here's a word
from today's video sponsor nordvpn look
everybody uses the internet slightly
differently and that's totally fine but
you don't want to do is use the internet
unprotected you may have heard me talk
about what nordvpn can do for you
previously encrypt your internet data
and move your online activity to another
location with just a single click either
for security or streaming all that is
still true nor vpn has more than 5 000
servers throughout 60 countries but vpns
give you access to so much more than
just new tv shows like what if you want
to buy a video game that's cheaper
somewhere else or maybe not even
available in your country well use
nordvpn having trouble connecting to
social media nor vpn want to root your
connection through multiple servers just
for double layered security yes totally
possible with nordvpn right now as a
special deal you guys can get a two-year
plan at a huge discount plus one
a bonus gift on top of that or just
follow the link below and now back to
today's video
as if the death of his mother was not
enough mozart was rebuffed by alicia
whose career was on an upward trajectory
this period was one of the composer's
darkest hours but it also contributed to
developing his maturity on a personal
and professional level for the moment
though the composer needed immediate
help thankfully leopold came to the
rescue he secured mozart another post at
the salzburg court in 1779 which in turn
earned him new work in 1718 mozart
composed his best opera so far edomineo
king of crete which attracted the
attention of the court in vienna
wolfgang returned to the austrian
capital in 1781 and to save on rent
money he lodged with the webers it was
at their home that he met alessia's
sister constans the composer was smitten
he simply had to marry the girl on the
one hand he didn't dare inform his
father as leopold considered the webers
below his standing on the other hand
constanza's mother pressured them to
formalize their affair but before tying
the knot moat sad had business to do in
july of 1782 he completed one of his
most famous operas the abduction from
the cereglio this exotic work set in the
ottoman empire is the first opera in
which mozart left his mark on the plot
and characters he established certain
recurring elements such as the
complexity of the female characters who
were better developed than their male
counterparts and the dramatic action
never resolving into a fully positive
outcome even offstage the outcome was
not as positive as expected despite the
success in rave reviews mozart received
a fee of just 100 guilders not enough to
grant financial security nonetheless
wolfgang and constans got married on the
4th of august in saint stephen's
cathedral
in june of 1783 the mozart's welcomed
their first child raymond leopold sadly
he died in august the couple went on to
have five more children but only two
survived infancy the grief of losing so
many children weighed on constance
already beset by chronic ulcerated
varicose veins wolfgang was in constant
need of cash to pay medical bills sure
but also to sustain a dissolute
lifestyle of partying and drinking that
was well beyond his means thus he
plunged into one of his most productive
periods earning 460 guilders in a year
but mozart was still not satisfied he
was craving for new material to compose
his next opera but the narrative of
musical conventions at the time did not
provide any exciting inspiration
librettists of the time also complained
about the fact that the musician wanted
to meddle in their realm criticizing and
rewriting their scripts the right
occasion arrived when mozart met lorenzo
de ponte librettis who had already
worked for salier the italian court
composer may have held some grudge
against the younger rival for poaching
his star librettist but that grudge
never developed into the homicidal
hatred portrayed in theater and film
actually solari had a very good chance
to get back at mozart and deponte in
1786 joseph ii challenged mozart and
salieri to knock their opratic socks off
at a special event a double feature show
in which two one-act operas would be
performed back-to-back the audience
would crown their favorite performance
mozart's piece was the impresario a
musical comedy about the production of a
musical comedy salieri composed a more
ambitious piece in opera set in the
world of opera so it was all rather meta
at the end of the evening salieri was
crowned the winner by the emperor and
the audience so why would he hold a
grudge beyond that in any case salieri
was the most successful and better
enumerated of the two rivals the two
respected each other's music salieri
frequently directed mozart's
compositions and was even happy to hand
over projects to wolfgang when he was
too busy so mozart and daponto really
needn't worry about salieri scheming in
the shadows the first collaboration of
this dream team is in our humble opinion
mozart's finest work the marriage of
figaro the source material was a comedy
by french playwright beaumarshay it had
a revolutionary subtext as it pits the
commoner figaro against the lustful
count of alma viva mozart and deponte
toned down the anti-aristocratic themes
to avoid censorship but their work was
still revolutionary at least in musical
terms and yet the viennese premiere on
may 1 1786 left the audience puzzled the
work was too complex too ahead of its
time but mozart was invited to perform
the opera in prague here the success was
phenomenal the piece remained on stage
for three weeks and mozart was rewarded
with a thousand gilders the prague scene
commissioned another opera from mozart
and dupont the don giovanni before it
was completed the earpod mozart died on
may 28 1787
throughout his life leopold had been a
constant presence in wolfgang's life he
had been his teacher his manager and
even his friend and confidant it was
evident that leopold's influence was
always at risk of becoming overbearing
the father worried genuinely that his
son would squander his talents in later
years leopold was more worried that
wolfgang simply squandered his own
fortune as he lived well beyond his
means while wolfgang appreciated
leopold's advice he had actively kept
him at a distance to protect his
independence the caboza poured his grief
and unresolved issues into new
composition the unrepentant seducer don
juan can be considered as a proxy for
wolfgang the libertine is eventually
dragged to hell by an authoritative
paternal figure the murdered father of
one of his conquests who returns as a
ghost again the reception was terrific
and the play was very good but not good
enough to relieve wolfgang and constance
from their mounting pile of debts not
even the long-covered deployment as an
imperial court composer in december 1787
could help him balancing the books in
1788 and 1789 the struggling mozart
accepted the help of fellow freemason
prince liknowski the prince organized a
tour in dresden and berlin but the
german-speaking world was less
appreciative than czech audiences
eventually the prussian court offered a
lucrative fee for a series of string
quartets but as we know these did not
come easy to mozart and he never
completed the work the composer returned
to vienna and to constance in july of
1789 the couple welcomed their fifth
child but the baby girl survived only a
few hours constance fell ill again and
the cost of treatments further weighed
down on the family finances
during these difficult days mozart
finally had a break the emperor himself
joseph ii had commissioned a new opera
from him and deponte cos fantute or thus
do they all it premiered on the 26th of
january 1790 but the emperor was ill
with tuberculosis and didn't attend he
died shortly there afterwards succeeded
by his brother leopold ii the pneumonic
was less musically inclined in 1791
mozart could not hope for patronage from
the court with constance being treated
in barden he felt depressed and lonely
but he still had some friends one of
them was singer and freemason brother
emmanuel shakineda mozart and shikoneda
thought of dabbling in a popular genre
of the time the magical opera in the
german language the result was the magic
flute the opera outwardly presents
itself as a fairy tale but it is imbued
with free masonic symbolism and
humanistic ideals the magic flute
premiered on september 30th 1791 it
became a huge success one alas mozart
could not fully enjoy his health was
deteriorating due to rheumatism swelling
fevers and persistent depression
moreover it was just overworked while
composing the magic flute he had to
accept the commission for another opera
la clemenza de tito required by leopold
ii for his coronation ceremony mozart
took on a further request by an
anonymous messenger a masked cloaked
stranger required mozart to compose a
requiem the music to a funeral mass
wolfgang interpreted this as a sign of
approaching doom he was seriously
convinced he was being poisoned as he
wrote in a letter i know i have to die i
write the requiem for myself by the way
the mysterious patron was not antonio
celieri as portrayed in the amadeus play
and film he was an amateur composer
count walzeg stupak who intended to
present the requiem as his own
composition and nobody was poisoning
mozart to date there are more than 130
theories and what exactly was the
composer's illness ranging from mercury
poisoning to syphilis a 2009 study found
that the mortality of young males in
vienna was well above average in 1791
and 1792. this may be linked to an
epidemic of streptococcal infection
which caused kidney failure so that may
be the cause and it is compatible with
mozart's symptoms by november of 1791 he
was confined to bed feverish swollen and
drained of energy his condition worsened
on the evening of december the 4th and
he called for the doctor when the
position drew some blood the composer
lost consciousness at 1am on the 5th of
december wolfgang amadeus mozart died
age 35 a life cut short too soon he left
behind an unfinished requiem as per
funeral regulations of the time he was
buried with very little ceremony in a
grave shared with four other bodies his
final resting place has never been
identified now we feel today that
discussing mozart's legacy is a bit
superfluous what i'd like to do instead
is stress again how wolfgang amadeus
mozart achieved apparent effortless
purity and beauty in his music as albert
einstein put it one feels he merely
found it that it has always existed as
part of the inner beauty of the universe
waiting to be revealed but what he
achieved he did from a state of constant
practice in a struggle
and personal turmoil
[Music]